I
became a Christian about six years ago I
spent a lot of my life as an atheist and
I'm so ashamed to say that I don't like
the word I think it's a bad word
nowadays because I was young and naive
and stupid enough I think that people
could be perfectly moral and live in a
perfect harmonious Society without the
need for religion and about six or seven
years ago I looked around the world
literally at what people were doing the
massive fetishization oh God I'll call
it of abortion
um you know the the degeneracy in
society and everyone's an atheist I
thought are these my people and I was
living in Romania the most Orthodox
Christian country in the world my
daughter's maternal grandfather is
actually an Orthodox Christian priest
and I picked up the Bible again and I
read it from cover to cover front to
back and that was six years ago when I
became a Christian